when we think about a chi nu we directly
think about his notorious idea of
absolute justice but do we really know
what that means
if absolute justice means following the
rules without any question wouldn't that
mean that a chi knew in his own eyes
fails to act justly when working with
the Warlord's or confronting the Goro
say no there is actually a deeper
meaning to the principle of absolute
justice and that is what we're going to
explore together today
a common misconception in storytelling
is the idea that talking about a
character is the same thing as talking
about the person that this character
embodies in the story you sometimes hear
people talking about whether a character
is good or bad based on the actions they
take in relation to other characters I
think that most of you probably don't
need me to tell you that a good guy can
be a bad character and that a bad guy
can be a good one
no matter if it's Hollywood or the anime
world's anti-heroes and great villains
have been a prominent element of
storytelling for quite some time now
however today I want to talk to you
about a different misconception that
people seem to be less aware of and that
is the big issue of whether or not it's
okay to like and enjoy an evil or
morally questionable character and as
you know taking a liking to the villain
of a story is a quite common thing and
yet often people get called out for
enjoying a character that clearly
commits evil or at least questionable
acts how can you like doflamingo
when he has committed so many acts of
violence and cruelty I think all of you
have probably had this experience before
what often gets overlooked in this kind
of argument however is the fact that a
character and the person I represent in
the respective world are not the same
thing liking a character and liking who
that character is are two fundamentally
different things indeed liking the
character implies liking the way that
character is designed and integrated
into the story this is pretty much
simply a question of good or bad writing
liking a person on the other hand refers
to liking their
their values and the personality so
liking the Flamingo for being an
excellent villain to Luffy and bringing
complexity and high stakes to the story
is essentially different from liking
doflamingo because heat ironically rules
and suppresses an entire country do you
see the point I'm trying to make here so
when we talk about a kind of today I
want you to be aware that I personally
don't agree with his actions and his
sense of justice as a person but I
nonetheless think that he's an amazing
and great character that I deeply enjoy
seeing in the story so whatever your
perspective on a kind of might be
remember to distinguish between a kind
of the character written for the story
of one piece and a kind of the person
acting in the world of one piece
therefore we will first look at his
character and how he's written and then
deconstruct what his sense of absolute
justice represents in the story after
all being one of the central antagonists
of the series sach uzuki doesn't have a
purely evil ideal Oda simply takes his
desire to bring down all the evil of the
world and gives it a dark twist in
perspective this is pretty much the same
principle he uses with Blackbeard's who
like Luffy follows his ideal of dreams
or like doflamingo who like white beard
follows the ideal off family according
to Oda the ideal you hold might be good
and just
but it's the practical execution of this
ideal that truly determines who you are
as a person
so let's find out what acai no actually
means when he talks about absolute
justice before we get into the steaming
volcano of personality that is a Kazuki
Aquino though a very quick update on our
small challenge once again you guys have
reached the goal I sent you and gotten
three thousand five hundred likes on our
key G's video so this time cut will
raise the bar significantly and
challenge you to reach 4,000 likes in
the very first 24 hours this video is
online and the next Admiral will be out
within the week but now without any
further ado buckle up it's about to get
hot
sikozu Keohane who is a muscular and
broadly built man that with over three
meters in height is taller than any of
the straw hats including even djembe his
design was based on the Japanese actor
Boonta sugawara with facial features
strikingly similar to his anime
counterparts in one of his movies we can
even see him smoking a cigar and wearing
the exact red suit with the pink rose
that we know all too well from a canoe
additionally za Kazuki also has a large
tattoo in the shape of a flower and
flame pattern across his left chest and
shoulder as well as a small tattoo of a
sword on his right arm
that might hint at the secret sword unit
inside the Marines naturally a canoe is
also a physically strong character that
also wheels the powerful mark melodia
devil fruit in fact he is so strong that
oda once even stated in an interview
that if a kind of were to become the
protagonist he would be able to end one
piece within a single year let that sink
in for a second born in the north blue
even as a child sac uzuki had a grim
demeanor and a sense of justice he
joined the Marines around the same time
as his fellow admiral Borsellino and
quickly rose in the ranks due to his
notorious strength a decisive moment in
his past was the incident of ohhara that
heavily shaped his idea of justice and
set up the contrasting relationship with
his fellow admiral Alka G during the
worid marine fort he was the decisive
factor to win the war in favor of the
marines and later after being victorious
over al-qaeda in the duel he rose to the
position of Fleet Admiral putting
morality and ethics aside here for a
second from a purely militaristic
perspective his appointment made perfect
sense being the one to ensure
whitebeard's death and carrying out aces
execution he easily outperformed his two
fellow admirals and even the former
Fleet Admiral San Goku during the war in
the context of these events oda depict
tsukino as a hard-line and almost
extremist
hurry leader that in many ways hints at
the strict and brutal militaristic
history of Japan that is filled with
warlords Shogun's and Generals these
were notoriously known for following the
values of their country but in the
process overlooking and stepping on the
people that they were actually meant to
protect in the first place
outside of his duties a kinda shows
little interest in anything besides
conflict and war despite having a
burning obsession to fulfill his desire
to eradicate all evil and end the pirate
era Zack uzuki is also a surprisingly
level-headed character who knows how to
constrain himself and not act
impulsively in fact this sense of
thoughtfulness and cleverness makes his
characters so fundamentally different
from many other villains that have a
similar basic design based on his
appearance and his extreme beliefs one
would expect a kinder to be an erratic
and impulsive monster that goes berserk
whenever something goes against his will
or hurts his pride
but just the opposite is the case a kind
is surprisingly determined on thinking
things through not in the way that
al-qaeda does of course determining who
a person truly is and what a specific
situation calls for a kinda much rather
determines how to get his desired result
in the most efficient and effective way
possible we can see this for instance
when he manipulates Quadro to attack
white beard or when he ruthlessly
destroys a ship full of innocents on
ohhara to ensure the success of his
mission and of course he also
manipulates ace into taking him on one
versus one by taunting his beloved
captain and in the end preventing the
pirate success at the war in close
connection to this a kennel also
strongly believes in thoroughness based
on his concept of absolute justice he
swears by the idea that you have to
finish what you started and if you
started you have to go all the way the
best example for this is once again the
incident of ohhara where after
sacrificing a ship full of innocent
civilians he states the following
golina language in other words a keynote
justifies his evil actions with the
necessity for thoroughness in the
context of working for the greater good
a concept that you might be well
familiar with from the Harry Potter
books
finally a canoe also has a strong sense
of pride pride in himself but in
extension also pride in the institution
of the Marines and what they represent
for the people while he doesn't feel the
need to act honorable especially in the
face of pirates he can't stand the idea
of the Marines failing to abide with his
absolute justice in the eye of the
general population this is why he is
furious with fujitora who shared with
the world what had transpired on
dressrosa after the flamingo's defeat by
luffy notably next to LKG we can also
already see a gaping hole between a chi
nose and fuji torres idea of justice
here most interestingly however is his
anger directed towards the girl say when
they tried to cover up the flamingo's
resignation from the Warlord's when they
dismiss his concerns for the public
image of the Marines it becomes very
clear that a chi note doesn't agree with
the notion that the institution of the
Marines is nothing more than a mere tool
for the world government that can be
used in any way they please so now based
on this premise let's determine what a
kynos absolute justice actually is to
learn where a kindness perspective on
justice for and we actually don't have
to speculate but simply look at the
master himself oda stated in an SBS that
the idea of absolute justice stems from
zack uzuki's decision to burn down
robin's homeland ohhara completely
without any chance for survivors in
order to demolish all evil on the
islands i think this is extremely
interesting since it not only suggests
that a canoe was not as determined
before the
but also because it shows us how the
same impactful event has brought -
initially not so different people
- morally opposite sides of the same
spectrum being confronted with the
extreme brutality of the Busta call a
kind of cope with it by justifying it
with the need to always be absolute and
thorough while al ki ji decided to go
against his superiors and fulfill his
own moral justice based on this a
kindness idea of justice seems to compel
him to always follow the law with no
regard of the situation or the people
involved rules are rules there are no
exceptions and no second chances
Zak uzuki follows this credo in the
belief that it's the only way to end the
root of all evil in the world the great
pirate era as a result he has definitely
heavily contributed to the marine
success in the past being the decisive
fact in the war his wits and
ruthlessness were the two major factors
in defeating white beard and finishing
aces execution a part of that is also
his strong belief in the meaning of
bloodlines while al ki ji looks at a
person's actions Aquino judges a
person's heritage as an indicator of how
big of a threat they pose we can see
this really well in the intensity with
which he goes against ace the son of the
Pirate King and against Luffy the son of
the most wanted man in the world all of
these examples show us the contrast
between the soft and liberal okichi and
the strict and conservative a kind of
when looking at these events one could
possibly find an argument that Zac uzuki
is simply a hardliner
that takes drastic action in a suffering
world however as we know a canoe is also
responsible for some horrendous and
extreme actions by which Odin puts him
in the clea category of an antagonist
one of the most prominent examples of
this is of course the killing of
innocent civilians on O Hara out of a
whim a decision that he made on his own
and not based on orders another example
would be him pushing for the complete
annihilation of the Pirates during the
war
not caring for the suffering of his own
men and the desire to stop the killing
in a way the worst example of this
however is the execution of one of his
own men for refusing an order without
any chance for a trial this has nothing
to do with justice or thoroughness but
is simply an act of tyranny and cruelty
we can see this behavior again when Kobe
dares to stand up to him during the war
his sentence barely being stopped by
shanks all these examples show us really
well how the wrong take on the right
ideal can create suffering for those
that were meant to be protected by it in
the first place
sacrificing civilians and soldiers alike
just to get the job done is not what
justice is about what is even more
interesting to me however is that a
kindness justice might actually not even
be that absolute after all there are a
number of things that should clearly
violate the idea of absoluteness working
with the Warlord's in other words
pirates should be impossible under a
kind whose idea of justice yet he does
it to make use of this strength ignoring
guano and not moving against the yonkos
should be a no-go when you want to be
thorough
but he decides against it well knowing
that his forces might not be sufficient
arguing with fujitora that cover-ups are
necessary while the existence of
cover-ups themselves should be
impossible under his vision letting
al-qaeda go after the duel
out of respect while brutally executing
a random foot soldier and last but not
least opposing the Goro say and world
Nobles while at the same time supporting
their system of slavery racism
exploitation and undisputed dominance of
the weak
how can you justify these actions when
your ideal is the absolute nature of
rules the answer to that is as
surprising as it is simple the kind of
Justice claims to be absolute in regard
to the rules of the world but in reality
it is based on his own set of ideals and
values so in the end he and alkie G both
ended up following their own sense of
justice despite taking opposite paths
after the destruction of oh ha
both want to achieve justice at heart
and are opposed to the actions of the
world government and yet they are as
different as it gets in the execution of
this ideal what all of this leaves us
with now is the hidden moral need that
Oda has given a canoe for his future
conflict with Luffy the need to
understand that evil isn't determined by
your blood or affiliation but much
rather by who you are as a person and
whether your actions hurt those around
you and even though he seems to have has
lost his path I'm sure he will get there
after all in his heart a canoe is
burning for true justice I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did don't
forget to hit that like button and make
sure to subscribe if you aren't already
part of the crew the winner of last
week's title contest for LKG is Matthew
Quan his title is al-qaeda cool song I
simply love it but I also saw many other
great ideas so make sure to share your
version for AK I know in the comments
I'm curious what you can come up with if
you feel like more one piece content and
want to learn about al-qaeda's lazy
justice next simply click here and you
don't even have to move otherwise I hope
to see you around next time and until
then have a wonderful week